each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'm very glad to introduce Michael Viper
oh he is a research fellow in the
Clayton school of information technology
at Monash University of Australia and
michael has attracted several awards
including the core australasian
distinguished doctor of dissertation
award for the best computer science
thesis of 2008 and currently he is
working on into it on tools which
provide a shouting and placement for for
diagramming so let's I hope it will be
very interesting to thank you love and
thanks for coming so this is work that
I've been doing as part of my PhD
research and I'm directly following that
over I guess the last sort of five or
six years it's collaborative work that
was done with a few people Tim Dwyer
who's now Microsoft but while he was at
monash university as well as kim
marriott linda McIver and peter Stuckey
so I just wanted to mention that this
talk today I'm going to talk
specifically about placement tools for
diagramming and these are things like
geometric tools for layout I'm going to
talk about the way that we are
advocating implementing these which is
via the use of of multi-way constraints
and I'm going to present to you some
results of some usability evaluations
that we did comparing multi-way tools
with with other solutions i'm also going
to talk to you a little bit about the
ways that we approach
connector routing in diagrams as well so
all right let me start out and give you
some motivation this is a an image that
came from just googling four phases of
the Moon so if you type this into google
you'll you'll get probably a couple
hundred images that show effectively the
same thing the different phases of the
Moon depending on the position of the
the earth and all the rotation of the
earth and the Sun one of the things
you'll notice looking at a diagram like
this is that you can immediately see
that there is intended layout or
geometric relationships within it things
are mostly in line with each other
labels are mostly centered with the
accompanying objects that their labeling
but you can also see that this is
something that has either been arranged
by hand or with a piece of software that
that probably didn't provide great
layout tools and I say this because you
can see the intention in the diagram but
you can also see where it fell down and
the intention is not being fulfilled and
that is that that certain objects are
not correctly in line and certain labels
are not quite aligned or centered with
objects so it's it's probably better to
create diagrams where you fulfill all of
these relationships because one they
just look neater but this is more
important because where you have these
these relationships that aren't quite
satisfied it's a little jarring and
these are things that that users will
notice and there will be this this
unintended implicature okay where people
look and and possibly see some
information that is is not relevant at
all and shouldn't be there so if
possible ideally we would create tools
that allow the user to fulfill these
relationships as easily as possible and
and maintain them throughout their
editing
so a few a few points of note producing
well laid out diagrams is going to be
difficult and tedious for users if they
do it manually okay you're often going
to want to be doing things like a lining
and distributing objects spacing them
equally now many existing tools have
automatic features for things like
grouping objects together connector
tools that will automatically rewrap
connectors as you move objects around
your diagram but these are not a
complete solution and don't satisfy that
the problem completely also some
existing software or a lot of existing
software just provide layout tools where
you select some objects and you click a
button then you say I want to align
these objects and and literally all that
happens is you get movement to a new
position and there's no persistent
relationship at that point when you use
these and you change parts of your
diagram you're going to find that you
need to repeatedly make use of these
tools to keep satisfying such
relationship so you have this problem of
repeated use where you're requiring
users through the same task over and
over again which is very annoying so
let's talk about some of the existing
tools the first one that that many
pieces of diagramming software offer are
what a call or what we're going to call
one soft placement tools where and these
are the ones we just have some shapes
you just select them in whatever way is
necessary and you apply a tool that
moves them to a new position and I'm
sure you're all familiar with this
because basically any piece of
diagramming software has this ability
I'm the key thing here is there's
there's no lasting relationship the next
way and this is something I'm sure
you'll be familiar with as well because
it's something that is offered by
Microsoft Visio as part of its layout
tools is the ability to
create one way constraints or what is
intended to be a persistent form of
alignment and distribution tools and how
these actually implemented is that you
have a guideline object that's added to
the page that represents your alignment
and you have a set of one-way
constraints analogous to formulas in
spreadsheets where you set the position
of a shape like shape I in this example
the exposition of it to be equal to the
exposition of the guideline in this case
the user can use the guideline as a
handler and object to to move the entire
alignment relationship so they can click
it with the mouse and drag it and
obviously like you'd expect in a
spreadsheet the formulas flow through
and the values update and your shapes
and move with it now there are some
issues with this or at least we
conjectured at the beginning of this
research that there are some issues with
this if you really want to use these as
your method for laying out objects
within a diagram you can have situations
like this so here's one of the basic
situations where this causes problems
okay we have some shapes a D&B we the
user select shape d and day and they
create one of these persistent
alignments so they have a guideline they
have the positions of these two shapes
have been constrained to that guideline
next they select shape d and they select
shape be and they create an alignment
with the bottom of these two shapes what
actually happens at this point is okay
the y position of beers constrain to the
guideline the Y position of D is also
constrained to the guideline at this
point it can't be constrained to the y
position of both these guidelines at the
same time all right so at this point
it's it's just constrained to the bottom
one and the user will not know this
though they can't tell looking at the
diagram at this point it's only when
I interact with it that they find out
that this is the case so when they drag
this guideline they find out that the
relationship they set up is no longer
there so a few issues that we felt the
were with with doing this via the
approach of one-way constraints firstly
it's not flexible yeah oh I'm sorry so
the first problem is yeah that it's not
flexible in the sense that the user
can't interact with just any of the
objects in the diagram they must
interact with the guideline rather than
the shapes the ordering of the way of
the order they apply the tools matters
so if they create one guy a guideline or
alignment before the other then
different things happen and finally they
can't evaluate the state of the diagram
at a particular point by looking at it
let's say they would open the diagram at
this third stage of that example I
showed they can't tell what's going to
happen next unless they either look at
the formulas that are actually enforcing
these relationships or they actually
move objects and see what how the
attachments are connected so what we
decided to do was look at implementing
these placement tools via multi-way
constraints so the idea here is that you
have a constraints over a piece of
mathematical software that sits behind
the diagram editor and handles these
relationships and instead you have
relationships that work in both
directions and what the behavior of this
actually means to the user who's
interacting with it is that they drag
the guideline and the shapes move with
it they drag one of the shapes the
guideline and the other shapes move with
it they resize one of the shapes the
guideline and the shapes move with it as
a result
so that's probably fine hola I'll talk
about the study and then I'll show you
what it actually looks like so the first
user study we actually did in this area
was we looked at using Microsoft Visio
and we did this because one it was a
sort of leading tall and it's it's class
of tools also because it had a plug-in
interface to it which meant we could do
some of this stuff and finally because
it already provided once-off placement
tools as well as one way
constraint-based placement tools and
what we did was we implemented the multi
way constraints and gave them an
interface and toolbar buttons and
everything so they were very very
similar to the the ones for the existing
tools and then we gave uses a set of
tasks that required them to create these
relationships and then modify the
diagrams and interact with them and
these were this was sort of real world
layout task I'm not going to go into too
much detail about this because in some
sense I feel this study was flawed so
I'm not going to tell you too much about
it but basically the only thing that we
noticed that was statistically
significant in the results was that the
one way tools performed worse than the
others so they were just bad and this
sort of rien couraged our initial
feelings that there were severe
usability problems with them and what by
what I'm saying by performing worse in
this case I am saying they performed
worse in terms of taking a lot longer
for people to produce the the final
diagram we asked them to produce and
also the number of errors of things they
could not get correct in the diagram
they're asked to produce now actually we
feel that the interesting thing is
multi-way didn't appear to perform any
faster than the other techniques and
so the the one soft tools the very basic
ones were just faster and and less
error-prone than the one-way tools in
these results really we didn't have a
high level of confidence in the results
of this and a lot of it we actually felt
would do to the ways that these tools
actually implemented in visio more than
because of the constraints of doing it
with one way constraints as opposed to
with multi weight constraints and what I
mean by this is some an example of one
of the the issues of the visio does is
if you align an object horizontally and
then place it into a vertical alignment
relationship it will actually break it
from the horizontal relationship even
though the shape has not moved
vertically so there's no need to break
it from that relationship and these were
things that we couldn't deal with easily
in the plug-in interface so we just
decided that we would reimplement a
prototype editor with similar
functionality so we could do a true
comparison the other thing that I will
note is that that some of the other
issues are that that users pointed out
in Visio when you create a distribution
relationship and it turns out this is
still the case with with at least Visio
2007 because we're having a look at it
yesterday that when you have a set of
aligned objects and then you distribute
them and space them equally there is no
on-screen indicator that represents this
relationship has occurred other than the
guidelines change from blue to purple in
color and at this point they behave
differently to how they used to and if
you drag one of the outer ones the
distribution resizes and you can no
longer drag the internal ones and often
the users we're trying to drag these not
understanding why they couldn't work out
what the relationships were on the
screen
so the next stage was i wrote a
prototype diagram editor and you'll
notice it looks very similar to vizio in
terms of its interface and the reason
for this was that really we were trying
to yet do a fair comparison against the
existing tools that were in vizio
against these sort of multi-way
constraint based approaches so it offers
the sort of standard diagram editing
functionality you've got cut copy and
paste and undo and redo and then it had
both multi-way and one wave versions of
these tools that behaved in what we felt
was the the best way possible given the
constraints of the underlying techniques
so i'll actually just show you what this
looks like so this is done up and
obviously we can just move objects about
you can select some objects and say
align them and we get a guideline here
that represents the the alignment and we
can move any of these shapes there's
also some connector routing going on in
the background which is why things move
around a bit if we resize any of these
objects you get the the relationship is
still maintained also there's
distribution in here and it looks a
little bit like this you can distribute
some objects you get an on-screen
indicator that represents the
distribution so this is I guess we're
trying to have a visual representation
of all of the underlying constraints so
you can tell what's going to happen
before you even interact with it also
this is an object that you can use to to
alter or to remove the distribution
relationship so I can hit delete and
remove the distribution relationship the
guidelines will remain I can resize the
distribution in fact I can choose to
resize it around any particular
guideline in here if I choose to
I can also add and remove objects to
these relationships and I can say delete
a guideline or remove it from a
distribution by dragging it out and then
this one is now free and the rest of the
distribution remains
so this next study we did we looked at
specifically the usefulness of multi-way
tools verse the one way equivalents and
as a secondary thing as part of this
study we also considered what the value
of having immediate feedback in such
constraint based tools was and what I'm
really referring to there is you'll
notice in done up here everything that
you do updates live all of the connector
relationships all of the alignment and
distribution relationships as the user
interacts with them they get immediate
feedback as to what's changing this is
in contrast to what you would see in
some other software where instead you
see you click an object and you drag it
and you see ghosted outlines of that
object until it's placed at a position
and then any updates that happen as a
result like maybe some connector routing
happen so we implanted both of these
versions so you can also drag these
objects and and then the constraints
update once the the user has finished
their movement action so some of the
exercises with things like beautifying a
diagram which is in the sense the
standard task someone might do if they
were just given a diagram that's been
very quickly arranged by hand and they
just want to align up objects and you
know space them quite neatly and this
doesn't usually require much actual
interaction with the constraints
themselves like it should be if you do
things in say an optimal order you could
do this with the same number of clicks
or actions regardless of whether you're
using sort of one-way tools or or the
one soft tools or the multi way but then
we got them to do some other exercises
which were things like saying okay you
have this diagram arranged you now flip
it to a landscape view and we want you
to rearrange it to make use of the space
on the page and and make it look
something
like this so what we were doing was we
were giving them tasks that had real
world motivation so they could see why
they were doing it they're also in some
sense a realistic diagram this is one
about just making a cup of coffee but
and we also suggest or said that that
these are the relationships we'd like to
be present in in the final diagram and
we gave them a few pages of printouts
that showed the initial diagram they
started with the target diagram both
with and without these indicators for
the relationships shown on them so and
then we looked at timings and and error
rates and things so this is an
interaction plot that shows mean times
taken to finish the tasks and also with
with error bars on them so the initial
things to take away from here are
firstly that the blue and green line
which represent the multi way tools are
overall faster to complete the tasks and
significantly statistically
significantly faster than the one-way
tools in general so that's just that the
the blue and green lines and that the
rep and their own era buzzer completely
below the red and black lines the other
thing to note is the the crossing here
basically where you see a crossing like
this it says to you that the tools
behave differently for different tasks
so in this case this first task was this
beautiful i one where it didn't really
require any interaction with the
constraints like actually working with
them once they were created so we ended
up getting a different result that the
immediate feedback tools performed
better than the delayed feedback tools
in this result what is perhaps
particularly interesting here is that
the delayed feedback versions
we're faster and this is a trend but
it's not statistically significant than
the immediate feedback and this is sort
of against what we'd expect because we
conjectured that this immediate feedback
who is beneficial to the user it should
make them be able to perform the tasks
faster because they see exactly what's
happening immediately and they can they
can do things without having to wait and
then ultimately go oh that's wrong I'll
now reset and and you know choose to do
something different so yeah yeah ah yes
in so in the sense that you could you
can just drop something and hit undo you
can also do escape in one in one of the
early ones we didn't have like hitting
escape during the action but we did
later on so yeah the first thing to take
away from this is is one way verse
multi-way constraints okay it's very
obvious that the multi way constraint
those tools are faster to accomplish
this task and they also result in less
errors what is interesting is that for
immediate feedback we know that there's
some value for comprehension involved in
this and specifically one of the
interesting things that were noticed
during watching replays of this
interaction is that participants will
instinctively shake objects of or sets
of connected constrained objects and
they sort of do this as a way of going
okay I'm just going to see how is this
object related to other things and I
just sort of move it about a little and
go okay that's what's going to move and
then I'll drag it somewhere else and
this is particularly interesting because
this wasn't part of the training that we
provided to users we didn't say okay
these are constraint based tools they
update live this is a way you might like
to use to understand how they interact
with each other this is something that
because the behavior of the tool is
quite a real world
approach all sort of metaphor for them
they they just make use of it and they
do that automatically the second thing
that's really interesting is that okay
the the immediate feedback did not lead
to significantly faster times and it
sort of comes to your question and we
went back and we looked at why this was
and it turned out that the reason it's
slower is that people have this this
system of real-world interaction where
they drag something they go okay no
that's wrong rather than realizing there
doing something wrong and taking the
easy undo approach which is very easy
you know you hit escape or you drop it
and you hit undo and everything jumps
back to how it was they don't do that
instead they they manually and slowly
drag objects back to where they are
originally positioned which is sort of
that I guess the the real world approach
of how if you were doing this with with
connected objects in the real world this
is what you do so we found this quite
interesting we suspect but we haven't
tested it that if you were to do
training on these users and and tell
them that this is a much faster and
easier way to do this you'd get by
without it all rights are you negate the
effects of this on I should say yeah
well they jiggle erjins ya did it end up
slightly changing their diagram you know
by a pixel here
I did it what I'm wondering is if you
were to add a feature where he mouse
hover over something it just uh no
jiggles everything connected to it sure
that would have helped it so I think
that quite possibly it would and I'll
just talk about this stuff in a second
so yeah exactly one of the follow-up we
did a follow-up study to this and and
this was also just looking at a little
more detail ways that we could possibly
avoid this problem of clutter because
one of the things that we noticed from
the very first study we did and the
later 1i just talked about one of the
common criticisms that we got from users
or ways that they felt that the software
could be improved was that there were
too many things shown on the screen and
this especially becomes the case when
you have lots of these constraint
indicators that represent and guidelines
and alignments and distributions the
other thing we did as part of this study
was looked at ways that we could
possibly help the user understand the
system of constraints that were actually
on the screen and particularly how
objects are connected because one of the
problems that I guess some of these
these users ran into would be I set up
these relationships but then sometimes I
still don't understand exactly how they
interact and they move something and an
object they don't expect to move on the
screen moves with it and they sort of go
okay why does that happen and it's hard
for them to figure out often the chain
of constraints that may cause this to
occur so that some of the stuff we did
here was we are there were there were a
fair amount of suggestions and these
also come from some suggestions that
have been made in literature on
constraints in in diagramming tools as
well because this is a well-known
problem this dish issue of clutter on
the screen we had some options where we
could we could try doing different
things and some of these were have the
indicators glow when they were active so
if you move a shape and another shape is
attached to it through a guideline you
have that guideline
glow orange and it sort of highlights
the fact of the movement and the
immediate feedback we think should be
helpful for this because it does motion
highlighting in a sense that you you see
the movement of all the objects that are
connected which is I guess why the
jiggling itself is useful we also tried
having just a constant reduced
visibility to these objects so they just
shone with some level of transparency
and also the other thing we tried was
looking at having them fade out when
they're inactive so basically rather
than glowing I guess they would be at
full visibility when they were in use
and then over say a couple of seconds
that would just fade down to reduce
level of visibility and what we found oh
and the second thing we did as part of
this tool was something similar to the
jiggling you're talking about but but
not quite and this was to have a sort of
query tool and sorry about this looks
terrible but it was with an old version
that showed connector points at all
times and stuff but you select an object
and then you can use brushing to
basically move your mouse cursor over
other objects in the diagram and see if
and how these objects are connected so
in this case this particular shape here
is connected through this guideline
which is attached to the dis elected
shape through this distribution to this
shape which is both Center aligned and
left aligned and through here and two
here so from the study our findings were
basically that the participants
preferred their preferred I guess
visualization for this was for the
indicators to fade when inactive but
remain it at full visibility when
they're in use when they were active and
to fade down to a just visible level so
really obviously you don't want to hide
something on the screen and have it
disappear completely that's going to be
terrible same problem we had initially
where the user just can't evaluate the
Staton and how the dioramas going to
interact before they
make changes to it also interestingly
this this took away the the complaints
that we had about clutter and we use the
same actual tasks so you would expect to
have got similar feedback where we got
say feedback on this clutter issue from
sixty to seventy percent of our initial
participants we didn't get it here
instead they complained about other
issues instead that they felt were more
problematic or of the ways the tools
could be improved by automatically
inferring alignment or distribution
relationships for them they sort of jump
on to the next level of what's possible
the other thing that came out of this
study was that this query tool of doing
the highlighting as you move around was
useful it helped some participants it
still did not get rid of this issue
completely people were still left going
okay um sometimes I want a some feature
at all they weren't allowed they weren't
able to describe how they wanted it to
actually react that gave them
information about how these connections
operated and no so in answer to your
initial question we did not do something
where they could say select an object
and have the accompany one's jiggle but
obviously it may not be required if you
have immediate feedback I guess because
the user can very quickly do that though
I guess it allows them to do it without
without while knowing that they don't
have to change the state of the diagram
in any way so it'd be very easy to
implement and and possibly quite useful
oh that slide wasn't supposed to be in
there so in addition to this we've later
moved to doing some automatic layout
stuff which I'm not going to talk about
today because tim has probably already
talked about quite a lot of it here but
you can approach me or him separately I
guess if you're interested in in more of
it but at the same time we switch to
using a different solver to
represent these placement tools and and
placement constraints and as a result we
implemented some further additions to
the placement tools we had available and
some of these things were automatic non
overlap of objects so this is basically
just that I'll just get rid of these you
can just turn on non overlap of objects
and as I drag them around they just you
know run into each other and can't cross
in any way it's bump into each other and
move also we created a tool for allowing
minimum separations to be specified
between guidelines so this is sort of
similar but not exactly like the the
distribution and again I'll show you how
this looks you basically select some
objects and say keep them separated and
again we get an on-screen indicator that
represents this separation you'll notice
it basically glows red when one of these
constraints reaches its minimum size and
you know starts interacting and you can
see as they bump into each other this
kind of occurs also you can click on the
relationship obviously remove it but
also resize this minimum separation if
you desire and delete it as well also we
did page containment which can be done
very easily with these these same
separation constraints so objects now
are placed within the page but because
you still want to allow the user to have
what feels like full control over the
application you want an object that's
dragged with the mouse to still follow
the mouse as you move things so you want
to make this constraint on the page
stronger than the one that holds the the
dragged object to the mouse cursor so as
a result it can sort
still balloon out sometimes so if i push
an object with the one I'm holding with
the mouse it will it will go outside the
page but then if I let go of it it'll
spring back or if I just you know move
it out of the way you see the page
spring back and and again all of these
tools we're working on our aim with them
is to take tasks that the user would
usually fulfill manually or with a
repeated process and instead make the
the diagram editor maintain them
automatically while still giving the the
control to the user to be able to alter
these relationships and I guess direct
how they behave the other thing that
that we've really been trying to do as
part of this is make sure it's very
clear to the user the behavior of them
based on the on-screen representation so
I guess we've worked hard on what what
it should look like when when things
like this these page layout constraints
are not quite satisfied or when you
actually I guess what different
constraint relationships should look
like so I'm going to stop talking about
the placement tools at this point and
talked for maybe the next 10 or so
minutes about connector routing that
we're doing and again you've seen it's
just going on in the background of Donna
as I was doing this we're using an
approach for this this polyline
connector routing and in fact we're also
doing this for orthogonal routing which
I'll show you in a moment where we
construct a visibility graph of which
objects can can see which other objects
and then we do a search through this
graph and find paths and then we do like
a final stage that improves these these
routes
where necessary and we particularly
choose this approach because it gives us
a lot of flexibility which i think is is
really important or beneficial in the
context of a diagram editor where if
you're in a diagram editor often the
user is going to have certain
diagrammatic conventions that they're
following obviously a lot of the time
aesthetics of the diagram are important
for readability or all of the time so it
it's fine i think to take say just
optimal approaches from literature for a
certain problem but then quite often i
think there's a need to adapt these and
give them some flexibility to make them
more useful within this particular
context so the key reason we chose these
is really this flexibility to capture
certain diagramming and drawing
conventions and aesthetics so like as an
example of this I'll show you first of
all like what is actually happening here
is this is the visibility graph in this
case it's basically a graph that
connects all of the corners of all of
the shapes as well as the connection
points and it's not a complete graph in
the sense that there's no need to have
certain edges in it like there's no need
to take the bottom right corner of this
shape and the top left of this one
because nothing would ever go directly
from those corners it would always you
know come around the shape or come from
a connection point that was inside it or
similar but then when you're actually
doing the the determination of the paths
through here and I realize I don't have
exactly the right demo so I've just
started up manually tests demos
we're using an a-star approach or search
through here and we can change the the
cost function to add penalties to it and
as a result we can change the the
properties of the rats that are produced
so one of the things is you might go ok
i want to have penalize sharp angles
within these connectors and you as you
move up this penalty you start getting
sort of better routes for it you could
also just penalize strictly the number
of segments in the connector and you'll
see as you raise this penalty you start
getting getting rapped to the possibly
more aesthetically pleasing to the user
one of the one of the improvement
techniques we use in these kind of cases
is where there's their shared paths or
wraps that come together is cases like
this where things go around the corners
of the same shapes you obviously want to
avoid this because it's hard to for the
user to tell exactly which path is which
other than obviously clicking on them
and seeing one selected but not the
other so we do a stage where we
determine ordering of these things and
we actually nudge them apart so that
there's space between I can actually
show you in this one but i'll show you
in the next one what this looks like
there's some some issue with it right
now yeah yeah well because and I guess I
could trace some of the produced
diagrams for it maybe after the talk
come and see me because yeah like that
it's quite common that you might have a
couple of connectors run from here and
then they also run like together down
here and apart later and it's it's it's
just really hard to follow them right so
if you can do this there's a couple of
things you can do right and and this is
really the benefit of the approaches you
can look for these crossings once you've
generated all these paths or even do
this on the fly when you're first
generating the paths and
part of your cost function you can
actually look for these crossings or
shared paths and penalize them depending
on their actual properties so if they
run in parallel but then diverge and you
know that they don't cross during the
course of their shared path it might be
fine to to leave the routing like that
and just nudge them apart but if they do
cross it might be that for one of them
you want to try searching for a
different route for it which might be
slightly longer but may have no
crossings to it and you can do this for
like do crossing detection for all these
things while you're routing but it's you
take a penalty like a speed hit for it
so I had actually the way I've actually
implemented it in here and and I
probably advocate doing it is to do all
the initial routings and then look for
problem cases so like do crossing
detection there once for everything and
if there's particular things that you
want to fix you do it at that stage and
ideally in an interactive context like
this the user physically just select
something they don't like and says hey I
want to rewrap this connector and I
don't want the crossings and and it
fixes it so this approach also works for
the for the orthogonal case and this is
I guess important here for you guys as
well I know you're working on this a bit
as well like this is the this is the
orthogonal connector routing in in Visio
and there there i'd like to point out
like a couple of things that are really
I feel problems with it first one is you
get issues like these where you can't
tell exactly where the piles go so the
overlaps a problem second is you can see
some artifacts in the routes or the
layout of the technique that is used to
actually determine the paths here so and
this is this is basically where does
this line segment end up does it end up
against shape f or does it end up
against shape e and this this will be
dependent upon probably the the
direction that the search is performed
when looking for these these routes and
the interesting is as you move things
about these change so it's not at all
predictable for ya and I think I agree
that's what what it looks like here but
really the issue with this is that a
user who is using it shouldn't have
shouldn't need to have any idea of what
the understand the underlying algorithm
is that's being used right the tool
should behave predictably and and in the
same way regardless of say the direction
that the routings performed so ideally
like this would be centered in this
space and likewise for the line up here
and we do something about about this so
this is all stuff that we can do by
using these these kind of approaches
that I talked about so that this is this
and this is with rounded corners but it
doesn't have to have rounded corners
looks a little strange so this is what
the same diagram looks like in done art
here's the visibility graph that it's
routing through and I can show you what
the sort of interaction looks like as
you move things around you can see this
this segment here is is centered between
these objects and you can see the sort
of behavior as you move things around
the top ordering here is a bug I don't
know what's going on there I was working
on an optimization for this that may
have broken some some things also the
case I haven't implemented is is the one
where you just block the visibility
because let me see if I can do this
somewhere like here this is just where
it doesn't have a line of visibility
anywhere because these shapes actually
overlapping something smarter needs to
be done here and this is actually
because there's a port on the top of
this shape so it's not this shape has
visibility in all directions which
ideally if it does like these the cases
don't really occur I mean we could
actually do that here I guess if you
connect to the center of this shape you
and maybe I should point out the the
other the other part about this is the
how we handle connection to like the
center of shapes here is you actually
just have a point of visibility and
special edges within the visibility
graph that just give you connection to
the ports on the side of a shape and it
will automatically just determine the
closest one based on that search anyway
so there's no extra sort of logic that's
required in in your algorithm as part of
this so there's there's a few tricky
things that are done as part of the
improvement step of this the first one
is you need to do this this sort of
detection of things like crossings and
ordering
can you sorry crazy leaf and importantly
anywhere on the time yeah yes so I'm of
a shape um yeah the ones in the ones in
done out right now have fixed ports on
the the middle of each side of the shape
but there's there's no reason you can't
place a port anywhere if you come and
see me over after the talk this actual
research is is being funded by an
industry collaborator who's actually
interested in this for circuit diagram
layout and quite obviously they have
their objects are like integrated
circuits with with pins all along the
sides of them and one one object might
have you know 20 connections or whatever
so yes it certainly works effectively
all you're doing is you're just placing
a point that you're giving visibility in
a certain direction and sometimes it has
visibility through the edge of a shape
if it's contained within that shape the
other nice thing about it is we do this
these this nudging step right that
nudges apart these shared paths and in
fact does it when they flow through
multiple segments and what that actually
is doing is it's firstly determine
determining an ordering for these things
that prevents them from crossing or
makes them just cross once if there is a
crossing that could not be avoided and
then it's determining the area of free
space it has in the dimension that is
doing the nudging and if you would like
your ports so in this case we have two
connectors that are going to the same
port on a shape but there's absolutely
nothing from stopping you from doing the
nudging for those final segments so in
this case because our channel of free
space is here we would actually nudge
just within the line of visibility and
up to the edge of the shape there and
the nudging would just spaced them out
equally along the that shape from their
center so effectively you get sort of a
nice space layout in that case for free
without doing any extra work okay so I'm
not going to go into any more detail for
that because I guess my
our here is about up so I will conclude
but you're welcome to come and talk to
me and I can show you further demos of
these things or explain to you exactly
what's being done in the background so
the key thing I want to I guess I really
want you to take away from the talk is
that we can certainly provide both
layout tools and connectors that
automatically maintained say drawing
styles and features also that allow the
user to customize the layout and that
also save the user a lot of effort okay
so a lot of these things can be done
automatically but they can be done in a
way that's well a way that is done well
and is predictable for the user but also
gives them flexibility I think it's
really important to make these things
behave not truly optimal but in a way
that the user can understand and and
work with easily and I also think that
the interface for a lot of these tools
is really important and I think that
these are points that are often
forgotten so at that point I'll say if
you're interested in further information
unlike these user studies or the
research there's my website which is
here monash at the top all of the
underlying methods were using for doing
both the connector routing and for doing
the constraint solving and things are
part of a set of c++ class libraries in
the adapter grams project and my
prototype editor is also available as
some binary downloads at the moment but
the source will be available sometime
shortly as well and i will say thank you
for your attention
missions I guess what I find very thank
you
Michael mentioned a company
these subsidizes
so they don't keep the result of the
crap
so the interesting is they basically
came to me and they said we've seen
you've done this polyline connector
outing and I said yes and they said we
also see that you say that you're
planning to do this orthogonal version
have you done it yet and I said no and
they said could you do it quickly we
have a you know release coming up in
four months or something we're
interested in this I said yeah it'd
probably take a couple of months of work
to do an initial version it won't be
great but we can investigate how to
optimize it later and they said okay so
how much will it cost this kind of thing
and we said can visit what we'd like
we'd like for the university to own the
intellectual property and the weird
thing is the library was already open
source it was already open yet they
could already have used it but they
preferred to pay us an additional
licensing fee and get the rights to
basically use it without telling anyone
they were using it and to not follow the
license restrictions which is not
providing source code for the library
and not providing basically dynamic
linking of the library yes so and that's
big that was okay because the only
authors of it up myself and monash so
yeah so it's jill license but they are
completely happy for the work to be
published which is why i'm actually here
because I was in Chicago last week
presenting the orthogonal connector work
and also via the implementation is all
is all open source and in fact the
implementation has of the orthogonal
connector routing has just been put into
inkscape as well the open source vector
graphics editor that sort of competes
with them adobe illustrator so that's
going to have some orthogonal
diagramming capabilities so I had a I
was mentoring a Summer of Code student
over the last couple of months doing
this
say that this leap aboard yeah yeah that
shouldn't be avoided yeah this is that's
right so you mention for for their ports
yeah pro I the port she's only did pop
yeah yeah certain puns and if you don't
provide the entire surface no so in fact
all I'm doing it so you could okay if
you're worried that you won't have like
visibility to the center initially you
could you could certainly do this at the
moment all I'm doing is I'm just
providing a single port and if I want to
space things out along an edge of a
shape or I just do it at the improvement
step when I do this nudging which is
I've got a path that I know goes through
there I've got some free space that I
can easily determine and how I do this
is I sweep through the diagram and look
for these channels so I know where the
obstacles are and how much edge how much
space I have to the edge of the shape
and then I know also the ordering that
is required to prevent crossings and
then at that point I just spaced them
out but if you were worried that you may
not have visibility to the center you
could certainly provide like I don't
know three of these but you don't need
very many like equally spaced along
there or something I don't think there's
a need to have you know 20 of them at
close intervals and do it at the routing
stage it's going to be a lot more costly
at that point to try and work out where
the crossings are and where the ordering
needs to be to avoid the crossings so
that the code that's used for doing this
some that's used to do the ordering it
is basically similar to the approaches
that are used for determining like metro
line crossings yeah
Chuck trip again disco thank you